we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's a
voicemail i don't completely understand
take a listen to this hey david Sackman
this is jack down here in texas and i
think you're doing a great job buddy
thank you for young guy and and you're
going to grow up and be a great democrat
someday thank you doing a good job back
what does that mean someday I'll grow up
to be a great Democrat number one I've
never been a Democrat and number two I
don't look forward to someday being a
Democrat I've been I've been independent
or as it's called in Massachusetts I
think it's unregistered or some
unaffiliated since I've been 18 years
old I don't know what this caller's
talking about and you do pretty well for
a young guy right I mean I guess it's a
compliment you just take it as a
compliment I guess so I just don't know
what the what the caller is suggesting
about someday I might be able to be a
good Democrat maybe he knows that you're
unaffiliated in the state of
Massachusetts but one day you'll have
the courage to check that box next to
the word Emet I guess so are you us are
you affiliated or are you unaffiliated I
actually am and I probably shouldn't be
not like I would vote for Republican I
can't imagine with I had the choice that
would I would choose the Republican
ballot wait you are what you are dammit
really I'm a registered it okay very
good all right we'll listen on the
enough about Pat's voter registration on
the bonus show today my vacation stories
Pat's vacation stories I will tell you
about the week ahead I will tell you
about an inquiry I received from a media
outlet in Russia and a lot more david
pakman.com slash membership is the one
way to get access to the bonus show you
can also contribute to our patreon
fundraiser at patreon.com slash david
pakman show I'll talk to you on the
bonus show